we thank you so much for coming today I
really appreciate you taking the time to
speak to me appreciate that so my first
question for tekken 7 will there be
legacy support for older arcade sticks
Oh manya first time Chris Amon Susan the
good it will dig okay yes we do plan to
support a party's legacy controllers
obviously there's so many on the market
the [ __ ] hard to say right now all of
you know all of them are worried but
we're trying our best to implement
drivers make sure that a majority of
them work the phone is ringing yeah oh
no doc a seminar on Papa no no keep on
signal so yeah I mean even on the boards
maybe you saw them if you at the
tournament earlier our Australian office
had actually already support a variety
of different older controllers as well
so since it's already implemented it all
that obviously when it gets gets to
console it's going to be even broader
can you tell us there will be some
side or mini game police watches sports
or take involvement Mon all support oh
hey it's kind of hard because we want to
try new things as much as possible and
although we announce story mode here
which is quite different from anything
we've done so far there are some things
we have yet to announce so we hope
people look forward to it but we can't
see it yet so this second game is the
end of the Machine masago why did you
decide to end the Machine storyline when
it's been such a central part of the
taken series for so long Oh mom did so
obviously solver I guess more accurately
you could say that this story mode
especially portrays not necessarily the
end of the machine model saga per se but
kind of focusing on the conflict between
bula Heihachi Mishima in his son and so
you'll see have a final showdown between
the two boxes not only that in the
outcome but also a focus her cool
clothes on one why are they actually
doing work we will be trying to kill
each other almost every installment when
did you start creating the concept for
cousin me when she's been absent from
the tekken storyline so long Oh Arabah
edo moto moto set episode is 0
the game more [ __ ] awful so it's it's
been quite some time you know she as a
character in the story line and having
been saying she has been around since
you know early in the Tekken series and
then she kind of get as a rule as a kind
of appearing background character the
story she's been fleshed out a little
bit more from what up to ten years ago
but as actual concept about it if you
were to play her what Kyle character we
should be etc that's brand-new for
tekken 7 so relatively recently why
integrate our command to the storyline
where you can just like a furnace side
character Todd number for the guests
cool so the initial idea came roughly
seven years ago speaking with on a song
or the producer of the Street Fighter
series about how I'm willing to
collaborate set travel and Radha son
didn't really want to do the disc
collaborating like bring every writer
from an outside series Street Fighter
little world and just have it as like a
marketing tool but got to be much more
sensational what's more impactful to
actually have them involved in the story
line units and so since it was seven
years ago was what is idea initially
occurred in the meantime as people may
not have noticed or bad that he's been
kind of gently leaving the alchemist
story arc through the mainland to make
sure that it links into for this time
will there be an equal platform play Oh
cross and also Jesus takiyama well
technologically it's not that difficult
to accomplish and we have an idea of how
long do it if we have to do so there you
go it's more about policy i guess you
could say because you're connecting with
different platforms etc whether that's
pc
etc but also just specifically for PC
it's a platform it's very open and you
can do many things so obviously there
are certain group there that kind of
little cheese or something like that
before you go and whether that's true or
not there's still an image among some
gamers that if they were connecting to a
gonna he's on PC lumba so maybe it might
not be fair but that's all they're gonna
cheat etc so there is also probably the
main reason for implementing such a
feature is that you have availability of
so many more opponents to fight online
so there is that that benefit there so I
guess we have to kind of think of
overall the fighting game community as a
whole how do they want to see the game
with do they want to say implemented
there or not or in what manner these are
the kind of things we're still kind of
exploring so it's not decided at this
point hazel oh my questions like are you
doing thank you